let's add 536 to 398. i'm going to do it
two different ways so that we really
understand what this carrying is all
about so first we'll do it in the more
traditional way we start in the ones
place we say well what's six plus eight
well we know that six plus eight is
equal to
is equal to
14. and so when we write it down here in
the sum we could say well like the four
is in the ones place so it's equal to
four plus one ten so let's write that
one ten in the tens place
and now we focus on the tens place we
have one ten plus three tens plus nine
tens so what's that going to get us
one
plus three
plus nine is equal to
13 is equal to 13. now we have to remind
ourselves this is 13 tens this is 13
tens or another way of thinking about it
this is three tens
this is
three tens
and 100
and 100 you might say wait wait how does
that make sense remember this is in the
tens place when we're adding a 1 10 plus
a 3 tens plus 9 tens we're actually
adding we're actually adding 10
plus 30 plus 90 and we're getting a
hundred and thirty and so we're putting
the thirty the three in the tens place
represents the thirty so this is the
three the three represents the thirty
and then we're re or we're placing this
one in the hundreds place ten tens is
equal to a hundred and now we're adding
up the hundreds place
one plus five
one
plus five
plus three
is equal to let's see 1 plus 5 is equal
to 6 plus 3 is equal to 9. but we have
to remind ourselves this is 900 this is
in the hundreds place so this is
actually
this is actually 100
100 i want to make all the colors the
same
so this is actually
100 plus 500
plus 300
plus 300 let me get the color coding
right
plus 300
is equal to
900
is equal to 900 and that's exactly what
we got here
100 plus 500 plus 300 is equal to 900
and we're done this is equal to 934